see your one-stop shop for everything
comic book entertainment and we're here
awesome Congress takes over sixth place
are you excited cuz we're super excited
we're in southwest territory right now
but we're gonna be making our way around
the park this is baby's first time at
Six Flags by the way I'm a little
nervous I'm not gonna lie I'm a little
nervous but since there's deals with
Warner Brothers and stuff we are
actually able to write a superhero rides
Walter is there a one particular ride
you're really stoked to do my favorite
right here is Superman ultimate flight I
love that ride it feels like you're
flying that's how excited I am so we're
gonna go check out the rest of the park
come with us come see what it's about
hey guys we're in from The Dark Knight
coaster about to ride although I heard
that the weight of this ride is just as
cool as the actual ride itself so I'm
excited to check it out how about you
Anna I'm awesome I always love the like
Gotham subway system they've got set up
for this so I'm really excited to see it
again
awesome all right let's go
right yes
alright guys I'm here at the giant drop
I'm really excited to ride this
obviously I've never been to six legs
before Tower of Terror is always my
favorite Disney so I feel like there's
some kind of correlation I'm ready for
freefall so let's see how I like it
we are about to go into the new Justice
League battle for metropolis ride and
they've rebuilt the Hall of Justice the
Hall of Justice at the Hall of Justice
what about to ride a ride
all right me and ion I just got off of
rage of the gargoyles which is like a vr
version of demon I was so excited
because I I haven't done VRE a' and I
was really excited for like my first
experience to be on a roller coaster
yeah that was that was not worth it the
headset wouldn't stay on and I I think
I'd tighten my like five times it wasn't
fun
about to go on Batman the ride this is
based off the first Burton movie for
1989 and this line is really cool it's
really funny one see the line I'm
excited yeah Batman better better than
that I don't like the animal show
alright guys this is it this is my
favorite ride we're gonna ride Superman
ultimate flight and you actually get to
fly in this basically because you go
face like this way it's gonna be great
are you excited I'm super excited you
get to see all the prettiness of the
park and see all the people and then
just yeah it makes me giggle that's
alright but makes you giggle yeah yeah
that's gonna be great okay well I'll pop
it away
oh they're disappear
I don't know
all right I hope you've enjoyed this
special episode of awesome comics here
at Six Flags Great America and Gurnee
Illinois we had a lot of fun did you
have fun I had a blast yeah Heather I
had a lot more fun than I thought I
would and I rode a lot more rides than I
thought I would so I'm very proud of
myself
we're all very proud of your problem oh
yeah okay so I hope you guys have
enjoyed this past couple weeks you know
last week we're at Wizard World Chicago
Comic Con this week we're at Six Flags
Great America but next week we'll be
back on the set talking about the top
ten episodes of Batman the Animated
Series so we'll come back for that and
until next week I'm Walter Bernays e AK
am I an away
I'm Heather Roose and we'll catch you on
the next page copyright
you